your boss put a contract out on your
life yes so there's a two-part question
what does that mean actually in reality
and what was the most
most you feared for your life in your
entire years of being in the mob
well because i walked away from the life
i basically betrayed my oath and
persecutor put a hit out on me i mean
the feds told me that they said my
father went along with it you know i
mean i had all of that when i was in
prison that's why they locked me down
they put me in administrative detention
but um
let me tell you the deal you know one of
the one of the horrors of that life adam
you make a mistake your best friend
walks you into a room you don't walk out
again your best friend your best friend
or somebody close to you obviously
unsuspecting right you walk into a room
you don't walk out well i had that
experience one night and if you want you
know i can take a minute to describe it
i it was all gas business stuff a story
came out i believe it was a news day i'm
not positive that said that i was
getting powerful enough to break away
from the colombos and start my own
family total nonsense it was ridiculous
it was fiction and not there was no
semblance of reality to it
but uh you know i started real quick how
does something like that become news is
there like a competitor that decides
we're going to screw with michael or
let's let's you know
you know sometimes reporters just create
i mean i can tell you so many stories
that there was just no truth to them
they just create these things you know i
was pretty high profile i was getting a
lot of attention
and um
so guys you know on the street you hey
you know anyway he's turning in this
amount of money maybe there's more you
know it said i was making two billion
dollars that was not true
and so
you know persico started uh you know
questioning some of my russian
partners and you know word was going
around on the streets so my dad was out
on parole and he calls me up and he said
look we got to go to a meeting i go to
his house we're in the driveway speaking
and he says
junior wants to see us tonight i said
okay it's what time you want me to pick
you up because my dad was on parole he
only traveled with me because i tried to
keep him safe
and he said mike they want this a little
bit differently they want me to come in
first they want you to come in second
long story short i was a poet i said dad
you know to talk on the street why
they're going to let them separate us
let's go together we were both captains
at that point in time
we argued about it in the driveway i
think i might have told you this patrick
and i said
you know what dad i don't agree with you
but i've been listening to you all my
life if that's what you want fine
so um
i drive in it was late at night we had
to meet junior in a house in brooklyn
because it was a covert meeting he was
on parole didn't want to get violated so
jimmy angelina
was another captain and family uh i meet
him in brooklyn he says get in my car
we're gonna drive to where the meeting
is
i get in the car there's somebody
sitting in the back seat
never i recognized him but i didn't know
really who he was jimmy don't even
introduce me i get in the car and
he's very closed-mouthed he's not really
talking you know he starts talking about
the yankees you know i'm a die-hard
yankee i didn't want to hear about the
yankees at night
we get to the house in brooklyn
it was late at night and it was about a
30-yard walk from the car to the
basement apartment that we had to go
into
and i get out of the car
i'm assuming jimmy's behind me and maybe
the other guy behind him
and i'll be honest i'm getting scared i
said this is this is a bad setup what's
going on here now i'm thinking
everything's going through my head i'll
be honest with you
when i recount this
i can i can smell the fragrance it was
an august night
and i can hear the crickets chirping
that's how real this was yes
and i'm uh i'm walking down those steps
and uh i'm scared i mean my knees are
starting to buckle i i mean it because
when that door opens i said the last
thing i'm gonna see you gotta understand
i mean i've i've been around since you
were keenly aware of it at that moment
very aware why didn't you run you didn't
you know people have asked me michael
why didn't you cut and run and it wasn't
heroic it was robotic
you just become so much a product of
that life you say well this is it this
is it you know and that's what i
honestly thought
you know i walk in the door obviously
i'm here because if it would have went
the other way i would have walked in the
door would have been over but
so we have this whole big dang in there
questioned me about the gas business and
so on and so forth and i started getting
mad
i started getting angry because you
gotta understand i'm turning in a lot of
money a lot of money
and and this was my deal i mean i put it
together
and uh but then i said wait a minute i'm
here with the boss let me calm down you
know it looks like i'm gonna walk out of
here
and we get in the car
and you know
i was really angry with jimmy i turned
to him and i was really your friends
my good friend
and he said stop wait don't say anything
i said what he said you know you held
yourself pretty good in there tonight
michael this could have been a real
problem
and so now i got even more mad i said
you knew this
you're my friend i know you're my whole
life you don't tell me anything
so he looked at me he was smart guy and
he said if was the other way around
would you have told me
and i thought about it and i said no
damn
he said you know he says this is the
life we live michael he said you know it
as well as anybody you grew up in it
and uh and then i walked out of the car
i don't know if i ever told you this as
i i didn't know what to say i was kind
of speechless for a minute i go to get
out of the car and he grabs my arm and
he says to me i'm going to tell you
something you're not going to want to
hear this but it's the truth michael i
said what he said your father was in
there before you tonight he didn't help
you one bit
okay with that in mind well here's what
happened yes i'm walking back to the car
and i'm saying what what could my then
now that's all i was focused on what
could my dad could have done but knowing
him so well i know what he did
hey my son does everything i'm on parole
if he's stealing money i have no i he
just threw me under the bus he didn't
back me up why at all i don't know why
i'll be honest i don't know why i never
said a word to him about this i just
kept it and never never brought it up to
him no no i never said a word but when i
was writing my first book i put it in
the book
i had to it was too much of an impact on
my life
because i'll tell you this if that
incident did not happen
i don't think i would have ever walked
away from the life it was my dad's
betrayal in that regard now he denied it
that's not true he denied it but i knew
it was true
but if i said to myself this if this
life can separate father and son what do
we really have here
but the point being is after that
experience nothing really scared me wow
so what i did when i left the life i
said okay they're not gonna walk me into
a room i'm moving to california
i said
they're not they're gonna have to send a
hit squad to come and get me and i'm
prepared i'm not going to walk my dog at
the same time every morning i'm not
going to go to the same restaurant i'm
going to stay out of clubs i'm going to
be very disciplined they're going to
have to work hard to get me so i never
was in fear after that time
i just was careful
and talk about respect and loyalty a lot
right
but
is there any trust or even friendship in
this life you know there is i had i had
friends and i had you know i trusted in
people but you gotta you gotta
understand something when a boss gives
you an order it doesn't matter
that's it i mean look i had an
experience i had a very dear friend of
mine that got killed and i believe he
got killed for the wrong reasons and i
could not save him
and they warned me they said if you want
him you're in trouble
and you know i mean i still live with
that today that's a horrible horrible
thing
but
that's the thing the oath comes before
anything and if you're given an order
you've got to do it or you suffer for it
well michael yeah you know and i really
apologize if this comes off as
disrespectful so forgive me but i mean
how could you ever look at your father
the same way i mean how could you ever i
mean you're a father you're you just had
your fourth child is there anything in
the world
where you wouldn't take me instead like
my god like why would you what would
ever cause you that's that's why
sunny
the guy did 55 years he didn't need to
do 55 years
sonny could have easily worked with
anybody and you
you're not dealing with a regular guy
you're dealing with a true believer
mafia like mobster like that's my
opinion i think you may say part of it
that's a true believer but
it sounds like a religious history
articles written about sonny are very
different than anybody else patrick let
me tell you this about my dad this is
the truth and i and listen i love my dad
i love him like forget it you know so
but but i'm telling the truth about him
my dad's legacy in that life meant more
to him than anything that's what i'm
saying yeah he just wanted to be known
as the stand-up guy now you know all the
good things he said to you about those
guys when he talked to me
this life is full of michael i mean
you would tell me just like that you got
a why oh yeah life is like a wheel it's
going to turn the guy that loves you
today is going to hate you tomorrow we
would go through and he educated me
which was great good feedback with some
of that
great
whatever he told me was spot on there's
no doubt about it but i had a i had a
conversation with my dad once you know
and i said dad
you know
you don't understand you destroyed the
whole family he got very insulted i said
my mom 33 years without her husband's
your basket case my sister dies of an
overdose of drugs 27 years old my
brother drug addict 25 years turns into
an informant
you got to claim some responsibility for
this you said no way i was framed if i
wasn't framed none of this would happen
i said but dad you weren't framed
because you were a doctor a lawyer or a
priest yeah this is the life we lived
they're coming after us
and you sacrificed your entire family he
got very upset probably got upset
because he's very upset you were you
were close to the bull's-eye he got very
upset with me he would never accept
responsibility and and that's what kind
of
you know i was always when my mom and
dad had a very
a chaotic relationship they were always
back and forth they loved each other but
it was always a lot of hostility in the
house
and i would always side with my dad
always side with my dad and then towards
the end of my mom's life i started to
listen to her a little bit i started to
see things a little differently so when
i would approach my dad with that he
would get upset with me michael for
those of us that have no clue about this
we're on time i have one other topic i
want to go with so if you want to wrap
this up i got one other question i got
for you but please if you want to wrap
up
no so you know look i mean i love my dad
to leanne but we had a difference
i mean that that really impacted me
obviously you know that that whole
situation so it was just different
between us more power to you for being
you've been married now for how many
years 37 37 years
five kids you have seven total yes right
your family is happy they love you you
see them wanting to be around you that's
the biggest
uh way to judge a father or a parent if
the kids still love the dad after 20 30
years their pops and moms they do some
right if they want to be around them so
that props goes to you
but i'm telling you when you from my
experience when i was spending those
three days with your dad those three
times that we were with him
very different i've not met many people
like him he was a fully like true
believer like a
general like a jack nicholson from a few
good men that's like what are you
talking about this is
like to that point of conviction duty
yeah very beautiful very dutiful to him
now listen that doesn't mean other
people believe that that doesn't mean
you know you live that life so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]